welcome to the man of Recaps this is
Ahsoka season 1 Ahsoka Tanana was
introduced in the Clone Wars animated
series she was Anakin Skywalker
Apprentice she came to live action in
the Mandalorian season 2 where she and
Mando teamed up to take down the evil
Morgan elth now in ahsoka's own series
she tracks down the plot thing evil lady
was looking for she fears it's a map to
the Lost Imperial leader Grand Admiral
thrawn he's a military genius that was a
main villain in Star Wars Rebels and of
course the old novels before that you
can watch my recap to get the full Rebel
story but at the end Thon was defeated
by our hero the young Jedi Ezra Bridger
he got help from the space whales The
perill Who grabbed thron's ship and
warped him both out of there and thraw
is a serious threat his return would
unite all the EX Imperial forces and
kick off another War so now on the
rebels main plan at lothal we realize
this show is Rebels season 5 Ahsoka gets
the gang back together recruits Ace
pilot Harris andula now a general in the
new Republic and still hanging out with
the team's Droid Chopper the chaotic
Mayhem machine but the main focus in
this show is our rebellious Mandalorian
artist Sabine Ren apparently Ahsoka
tried to take her as an apprentice but
these two ended up butting heads but now
ahsoka's got the plot thing that can
help her find her lost friend Ezra but
Morgan eleth has just broken out of
prison with help from a new dark Jedi
Balin skull he has an apprentice evil
bangs girl and sends her after Sabine
for an apprentice fight sabine's out of
practice and she gets stabbed but don't
worry she's fine who needs a spleen
anyway so now Sabine is ready to get
serious ritualistically cuts her hair
all right to soak up let's do this she
starts training with ahsoka's Droid
huyang who was an old Jedi training
Droid and Sabine is a top tier fighter
but she doesn't have much connection to
the force Ahsoka explains she's a little
Force sensitive but way less than all
the Jedi we know meanwhile the bad guys
open up their space map which answers
how Ezra and Thon have been missing this
whole time I mean the Star Wars Galaxy
isn't that big relatively but turns out
they're in a different Galaxy which for
Space is really far away so saan and
evil bangs have their rematch while
Ahsoka goes for balence SK hey we never
met Matt who are you what's your deal
Well turns out he seems like a cool guy
who wants to do the greater good but his
greater good is clearly bad so he and
Ahsoka have a lightsaber fight and
balin's skull is no scrub he's got
Ahsoka on the ropes in fact who knocks
her off the cliff so Bean got the map
she's going to destroy it so they can't
find thraw but that would mean she can't
find Ezra either and so Sabine gives him
the map back taking a pretty big gamble
here so Balin enters the coordinates
then destroys the map so no one can
follow him and it's time for the bad
guys Intergalactic hyperspace jump
Ahsoka meanwhile didn't die she wakes up
in the world Between Worlds which we
know from Rebels is like a mystical Jedi
place and here she's reunited with her
old Master yes hating Christensen back
as Anakin Skywalker he tells her he's
got a new lesson for her and they go to
a flashback to when she was a kid
fighting in the Clone Wars she realizes
Jedi shouldn't be fighting in the war
Jedi whole thing they're supposed to be
nonviolent at the time Anakin thought
the only way to stop violence is with
more violence and now isoko realizes
maybe that was wrong and led him down
the path to the dark side so nowok and
dark side Anakin have themselves a
lightsaber rematch but Ahsoka doesn't
kill him throws the lightsaber away yes
a Jedi should choose nonviolence
meanwhile Hara finally arrives she was
caught up in New Republic bureaucracy
most people are trying to do good but
there's still a lot of secret Imperial
loyalists luckily C3PO shows up to shut
this guy down Hera brought her son Jason
sindula who like his father before him
is force sensitive and is able to figure
out where ahsoka's in the water with the
map destroyed Ahsoka can't follow unless
she asks directions from the perill
themselves yeah these space squid whales
are maybe super cute or maybe Elder
chores but ahsoka's not scared Parks
inside one's mouth for some space whale
Intergalactic hitchhiking meanwhile the
bad guys are in this new Galaxy but
turns out it's not a new Galaxy it's an
old Galaxy it's the original home world
of the night sisters The Witches of
damir of whom Morgan elth is a
descendant and now pulling up in an old
star destroyer oh yes it's the man
himself Grand Admiral thrawn he's ready
to come back and restart the Empire he
just needs a day to load up something
from the witch's Temple so for now he's
reunited with his old enemy Sabine Ren
and it's like yeah go ahead go look for
Ezra if she manages to find him you guys
kill them both so saine befriends some
rock Turtle aliens and who's living with
him but her friend Ezra Bridger all
grown up now he's grown out of beard but
the bad guys catch up to him and it's a
big fight meanwhile Ahsoka finally
arrives the space whes brought her to
the right Planet as Sabine has round
three with her rival evil bangs Ahsoka
goes for the rematch with Balin but she
runs away and he doesn't pursue balin's
skull has his own mysterious goal so
Ahsoka joins the fight and turns the
tide it looks like our good guys win but
Grand Admiral thraw is a genius
strategist this whole thing was part of
his plan he distracted them with his
least favorite Stormtroopers while the
rest of them finished loading the ship
they're ready to go back to their home
Galaxy leaving the good guys stranded
here but thron's not taking any chances
send some Tie fighters after them to
disable their ship but the Jedi just red
in on wolves so thron's backup plan he
sends more Stormtroopers at him but two
and a half Jedi can take down an
infinite number of Storm Troopers but
Thon had a Backup backup plan he had the
witches do a magic r ritual oh brings
them back as zombie Stormtroopers this
slows them down a bit but they're still
on their way to stop that ship but thraw
has a triple backup plan the witches
give Morgan elth their power and their
secret shadow magic sword she delays
Ahsoka while Ezra and Sabine are
ambushed by super strong zombie Troopers
saine's in trouble it's time for her to
figure out how to use the force oh grabs
her lightsaber takes this thing out but
the ship's getting away the only way to
catch it is with a double Force jump oh
the jump and push saine's going to do
the jump and pull but now ahsoka's in
trouble so just as it looks like
ahsoka's defeated Sabine jumps in yeah
she stayed behind to fight with her new
Mentor Ahsoka hang managed to fix their
ship so they've got a chance they can
still catch thraw but thraw still has
one backup plan left he opens a channel
just to say hey because he won they
can't catch him and he light speeds out
of there back to our galaxy leaving
Sabine and Ahsoka stranded but they're
not giving up there's still a lot of
mysteries about this planet evil bangs
is still out there she rounds up the
local barbarians like hey what's up I
guess I'm I'm Your Leader now and balen
skull is dramatically standing up on old
statues he seems to know something about
the ancient mystical lore of this place
what is his plan and watching over his
Apprentice Ahsoka is Force ghost Anakin
Skywalker yeah he made it to Ghostville
back in the main Galaxy a lone
Stormtrooper aboard the Republic ship
yes indeed it's Ezra Bridger who escaped
good news I'm back bad news Ahsoka and
Sabine were left behind and thrawn is
back too he's setting up at the witches
plan at damir he's got some secret plan
that involves all the stuff he took from
that witch Temple what's in these boxes
you know it's not good Grand Admiral
thraw is back and ready to revive the
Empire and that's where Ahsoka season 1
comes to an end if you like this recap
hit that subscribe button for more of
the best Recaps of TV and
movies